yNN's and feds law professor James
Jacobs looks at the infiltration of
unions by the mob and the power that it
gives organized crime in large cities in
the United States this is about 90
minutes
Jim is now the Warren Berger professor
of law and a director for research in
crime and justice criminal justice crime
and justice at NYU Law School and many
of us are a number of us attend he runs
a citywide program once a month on crime
and criminal justice NYU and and a
number of folks here are regular
attendance there as well Jim I went to
public school in New York in Mount
Vernon which I think it's a fancy
version of New York City goodness a
little away from the other no no and
Westchester then he went to Johns
Hopkins we got a BA in sociology then he
got a law degree from the University of
Chicago then he got an MA and a PhD from
the University of Chicago in sociology
but we all have weaknesses then he was
an assistant professor of law and
sociology at Cornell then he was an
associate professor of law at Cornell
and a professor of law from 1981 to 83
at Cornell in 1983 he became a professor
at NYU Law School and director of the
Center for research at crime and
criminal justice in 2000 he was awarded
or was given the Warren Berger chair at
NYU Law School brief brief mention of
his resume I mean this is I'm not even
gonna tell you the titles he's written
15 books 15 books and all this gonna
make all the academics you feel very
inadequate he's written over 100
articles on a range of topics everything
from organized crime and kind of stuff
would be speaking about tonight through
drunk driving and his one of his most
famous books was actually his first one
which is Stateville which is probably
the best book ever written on a prison
in the United States and it's still a
landmark in in every course on this
stuff now on Criminal Justice
well tonight's format is rather simple
Jim will speak for about 45 minutes on
us on on the st. on the title here which
is the same timelessness book but we're
not trying to sell this book it just
happens to be up here
monsters unions and feds if anybody is
interested I do have the press sent me
order forms you're not obligated to take
any of these what we do have them and he
will be speaking for 45 minutes and then
we'll have questions and answers Frank
hard tough questions this guy loves he
always asks tough questions and he
deserves to get tough questions and
after that we'll have coffee coffee and
cookies in the hall and a chance to
schmooze and talk and hang around so
without further ado Jim Jacobs thank you
Milt that was very kind and was also
kind of you to start my my powerpoint
presentation as well
Milt's an old friend and there's several
other old friends here and I appreciate
you all coming out and I also appreciate
the support for this wonderful series by
the Evangel itis family it's a pleasure
to be back as a recidivist I love
talking I love talking about my book I
think this is a fantastic story they
really the story of a century of
infiltration organized crime
infiltration and exploitation of
American unions and their pension and
Welfare funds and about a quarter
century of efforts by the Department of
Justice to remediate the problem through
the use of the civil racketeering law
and Union trustees appointed by courts
and supervising this remediation effort
I'll give you some flavor both of the
history of the problem the the deep
entrenchment of the problem and of these
efforts that remediation this evening
and I hope to leave a good amount of
time
your questions experience tells me that
there'll be a lot of a lot of a lot of
questions generated by this and and
that's that's great and it's great that
we have an opportunity to to ventilate a
problem and talk about a problem that's
been around for a very long time and
which is a really major chapter I think
in the in American history in the 20th
century this is one of those areas and
one of those issues that everybody knows
and that everybody doesn't know at the
same time so I don't think it surprises
anyone to hear that there's been
organized crime infiltration of labor
unions people have heard about the
Teamsters and they saw on the waterfront
and they know about the Longshoremen's
Union but yet open up a a labor history
book even take some of the standard
books of labor history two-volume book
and and count the number of pages
devoted to organized crime and I think
you'd be lucky to find five pages head
of a two-volume work on America on the
history of American labor open up a book
about urban politics in the United
States and I think you'd be lucky to
find even an entry in urban politics
about organized crimes relation to the
power structure of our cities I know
that as a sociologist I walk on somewhat
somewhat dangerous ground especially in
invoking one of the great lords of the
field Robert Dahl but let's just think
about mr. Dahl for a moment he he put
his political science mind to to a
question of great importance he asked
who governs he looked around he studied
he examined II he thought he dug and he
found the newspapers he found the
business community he found the local
politicians he even found the churches
but there was no no no organized crime
figure in sight
No Godfather no mafia figure and in his
account of who governed New Haven at a
time when any cabdriver
any construction worker you know any
owner of a small business would have
told him that the person who governed
New Haven was the Godfather there and
that if you wanted to get something done
that's where you would go so one of the
questions I think it'll come out of the
talk tonight in order come out of the
talk tonight is is is is what accounts
for the the intellectual and academic
blinders on this on this subject that is
it is pretty much ignored this whole
enormous phase and pardon and and and
chapter in American history
so let me say a few things about the
nature of the problem maybe I don't need
to speak into the microphone what is
labor racketeering ok so labor
racketeering I'm not just I'm not
talking about corruption all
organizations have corruption but I'm
talking here about the special
relationship of the traditional
italian-american organized crime
families to labor unions and their
corrupting of labor unions beginning in
say the 1920s and 1930s going becoming
very prominent say in Chicago during the
Capone years and maybe reaching a peak
in the 1960s 1970s and still being much
in evidence in many unions and the
nature labor racketeering involves many
different kinds of exploitation it
involves simply the exploitation of
Union Treasuries putting mobsters and
their their family members and their
mistresses onto the Union payroll and
paying them bloated salaries and and
reimbursing them for non-existent
expenses it involves the looting of
Union pension and Welfare funds in
through many different kinds of schemes
but if there's one point
that I can make and that I'd want to
leave you with tonight it is that labor
racketeering is essentially the sale of
the rights of union members the sale by
by union officials and organizer and
their organized crime allies right who
sell off the rights the collective
bargain to collectively bargained rights
of union members so if you can think of
a union which is thoroughly controlled
by organized crime say like local the
Teamsters Local 560 in Union New Jersey
one of the most the largest Teamster
local for a time in the entire state of
New Jersey one of the most powerful
teamster unions in the locals in the
country and a union thoroughly
controlled by the Provenzano crime
family a branch of the Genovese crime
family so what do they do and they offer
employers the opportunity to pay bribes
to avoid all the terms of the collective
bargaining agreements so that they don't
pay overtime they don't pay health and
welfare benefits they in fact can get a
collective bargaining agreement with a
low-price local rather than the
high-priced local in fact they don't
have to hire union labor at all if they
pay enough money so when the when the
trustee of the International laborers
Union a former prosecutor came into
office about ten years ago he told me he
looked at the collective bargaining
agreements that the labor laborers Union
had in a New York metropolitan area he
found that they had on paper they had
jurisdiction over all asbestos removal
in New York and then going around the
city he found out that they did about
10% of the asbestos removal in the city
right the rest was either done by other
unions or by no unions at all so that's
what I mean by labor racketeering the
the beneficiaries of the labor
racketeering are the organized crime
families and there
corrupt allies in the labor movement in
the unions and the losers are the are
the union members themselves what is a
labor racketeer labor by labor
racketeering is the term I'm speaking
here of organized crime members or
organized crime associates right not
made members but part of the families or
just labor people who are controlled by
and in league with and allied with
members of the organized crime families
the the gangsters got into the labor
movement even before the the rise of the
Italian organized American organized
crime families in the 1920s and 30s
there were gangsters in the labor
movement before that and the patterns of
labor racketeering were already
established by the 1920s and 1930s it
was not difficult to get into the unions
much of the infiltration came as a
result of the labor Wars which is a
particular facet of American labor
history that the the actual physical
battles between employers and and and
people trying to establish rights rights
of workers when the employers brought in
strike breakers the unions brought in
mobsters sometimes both sides had
mobsters and when the smoke cleared the
mobsters remained and in some of these
unions they then remained in control of
the union at other times the mobsters
just simply walked into a union put a
gun to the head of a union official and
said you know it's our union goodbye and
they they took it over that way
sometimes they ran for office and had
some specialty in rigging elections and
and corrupting elections so you can
think for a moment that even political
elections in the u.s. in the early 20th
century were not absolutely pristine you
know even when you had two parties and
there supposedly watching the ballot
boxes and so forth this didn't exist
in local unions we don't have that kind
of infrastructure so if you have some
tough guys coming in and they're running
the Union and so forth it's not hard for
them to simply dump out the ballots or
remark the ballots or count them by
logarithms or something like that you
know or you know so they didn't have too
much difficulty doing that and the
unions were very attractive to the
mobsters in the in the early in the
early 20th century because they they
could be first had had a lot of there
was always a stream of money especially
after the National Labor Relations Act
was passed in 1934 and the dues checkoff
began to become routine in many unions
so that you could sit back and you
didn't have to go out and get money
every month money was automatically
placed in the Treasury by the by the
employers and then you had complete
control over an ever replenishing
Treasury well that was pretty good and
then in the night starting in the 1940s
unions began to negotiate for pension
and Welfare funds these funds became
very large very quickly into the
hundreds of millions and even billions
of dollars some of you may know
something about the Teamsters central
state pension fund the largest pension
fund and Welfare Fund in the country a
funded did expanded into into many
billions of dollars and was wholly
controlled by organized crime and the
organized crime Godfather's appointed
the the trustees of the fund and they
ran the fund as a bank for organized
crime for many years and even in the
face of increasing investigations by the
IRS and Congress and and the the US
Attorneys offices the extent of the
problem and and people have often asked
me about well you know is this a big
problem how do you know how big it is
are we just talking about some kind of
some kind of of
sideshow in in the in the labor movement
but I to me this seems like it's a very
large problem there are difficulties
quantifying the extent of the the extent
of the problem I mean how do you decide
how big the labor racketeering problem
is do you count the number of locals the
number of district councils in which
there have ever been allegations or
proven cases or or how do we do that I
mean there are tens of thousands of
locals there having you know there are
only so many that have been investigated
is every local well you could do it that
way you could come up with a number that
way you could come up with a number but
but locals are of different sizes you
have some locals with with ten members
you have some locals with 10,000 members
so should we count them all equally I
won't bore you with all the quantitative
problems here but it is it is difficult
and and and then you also have to asked
about time frame do you mean ever having
had a proven relationship with organized
crime at any time what do you mean over
an extended period of time but I think
one way - one way to think about it is
that how many union members are affected
and there are hundreds literally
hundreds of union locals where there
have been proven connections with
organized crime
there have been the four big
international unions which were
corrupted at the top and then the people
at the top were able to place their
henchmen into many positions with within
in their Union so I'm talking about the
Teamsters and the International
Longshoremen's Association and the hotel
and restaurant workers union and the
laborers Union so those are our major
unions and you could argue that every
member of those unions was affected
right by organized crime either in the
management of their union and the denial
of their effectively of their right to
vote the right to speak their all of
their landrum-griffin rights and in
their pension funds and if that was true
then you could look the Teamsters Union
alone has had said roughly 15 percent of
all private sector union members are
just in the Teamsters member and
Teamsters Union alone so if you were
eight just add take those four unions
you'd have 2.5 million union members
affected by labor racketeering out of a
total private sector union members of 7
million so we're talking about what a
third of the members of union members
who are in you know in in really
mobbed-up unions and yet there are many
many other unions I mean the Carpenters
Union the the International Association
of stage and theatrical employees yachts
and the engineers general engineers I
mean many many unions that have to have
proven connections to organized crime
I not only talked about the
international unions the ones that cover
the whole international because it's US
and Canada but I have a chapter about
New York City and I just look at all the
locals in New York where there have been
proven connections between the Union and
organized crime and many of these where
the where an organized crime
soldier or capo is the actually the head
of the Union so what we've got here you
know in the 30 or 40 unions we've got
people who who have been investigating
this who say that there's every
construction Union in in New York City
has strong connections with with
organized crime and this isn't just a
New York story it's the same story you
could find in most American large cities
in the Northeast and the Midwest
certainly Chicago is every bit the story
is is every bit as as true and the
problem is every bit as as deeply
entrenched in Chicago maybe even more so
than in New York
it's you know very very deeply
entrenched in Philadelphia and in
Cleveland and in Detroit and in Kansas
City you know and many many st. Louis
and many other cities Pittsburgh in the
United States so this is not this is you
know a substantial problem and it's a
substantial part of our labor history in
a substantial part of our urban history
so why did the problem persist for so
long
well I mean there has to be some
explanation and one one thing that I
would note right from the beginning is
that is that there was very little
opposition I mean other than maybe maybe
the McClellan committee and and some
actions in Congress where you had you
had hearings and you had politicians
posturing in Congress you you had very
little opposition to this to this state
of affairs certainly there was no
grassroots movement like Mothers Against
Drunk Driving or something like this
where the people rose up angry to do
something about it so let's look at the
FBI
the FBI our national police force was
not interested in labor racketeering
indeed they were not interested in
organized crime until after the death of
J Edgar Hoover in 1972 so during the
years that Hoover ran the FBI which was
from 1924 to 1972 a very long time
the FBI was focused on subversives and
especially left-wing subversives and and
and it was it was clearly not focused on
on organized crime and mafia people in
fact Hoover denied the existence of of
organized crime over these over these
years state and local government and
business you had you had Alma
no real opposition from local
governments and local police departments
to organized crime generally this is
another sad chapter of American history
perhaps not appreciated enough by urban
historians and urban political
scientists is is the wholesale
corruption of local police departments
we know a lot about it in during the
Prohibition years but even after
prohibition the tentacles of organized
crime reached deep into into police
departments in the large cities and even
into prosecutorial offices in the large
cities and the business community as
well I mean if the business community
with all of its power had risen up and
demanded that something be done probably
something would have been done but but
there was no such a movement I mean
there were business groups that started
Crime Commission's and so forth good
good government groups yes that's true
but in the in the really corrupt areas
the businesses learned to get along with
organized crime and entered into
fruitful relationships with organized
crime and the the nature of the
relationship was paying off organized
crime so that they wouldn't have any
labor troubles when I began in this
field III thought about labor
racketeering mostly as extortion you
know shaking down businesses for labor
peace but the more that I've worked on
it and written about it and thought
about it I don't think extortion is the
main story i think the main story is
bribery that this is a productive
reciprocal relationship the businesses
are not the victims of this story they
are part of the of the perpetrators of
labor racketeering they pay off they
even seek out corrupt union officials in
order to get around there they're there
they're required to commitments under
the collective bargaining
agreements they were also in you know in
many of the very competitive industries
they reached out to mobsters to form
cartels so that they could block other
country other companies from coming into
a particular niche this is very true of
the construction area or waste hauling
or something like that and the Union was
perfect for enforcing the cartels so
let's say you took the waste hauling
sector or industry in New York City you
have them all signing agreements with
the Teamsters who are the drivers of the
trucks another company say a national
company wants to come into New York and
compete well they can't get drivers no
one will drive for them if they do get a
driver they drive themselves there their
their trucks will be will be sabotaged
they'll be picketing of the you know all
along the routes the clients will be
harassed there is no potential to
challenge and compete for business and
so up until the Giuliani administration
in New York City there was no national
waste hauling company doing business in
New York I mean was a wholly controlled
cartel and there were cartels like that
all over New York and all over the big
cities in the United States the afl-cio
well the the the story I'm telling about
about organized crime penetration is
true for mostly for the AFL the American
Federation of Labor which was the craft
unions and it was there that there was
was this gangster penetration these were
these tended to be smaller employers
competitive industries where the
employers needed the unions who
establish cartels and in the CIO the
Congress of Industrial Organizations in
those large
industries in there in those large
industrial unions they didn't have a
history of organized crime penetration
they did have a history of penetration
by communists and by socialists and a
much more ideological labor movement in
those places and where there was
repression of unions by the by the FBI
where the FBI did look into Union
matters it was always into the CIO
unions it was always into those unions
which were run by lefties run by
communists right and it was there that
we saw FBI action and they left the
other unions alone so for that reason
I'd like to to put forward the thesis
that we we didn't just wake up one day
and have gangsterism in the American
labor movement but that what we have was
chosen it was a it was a decision right
it was a choice and the choice the
country faced at least in the minds of
some of some people and some sectors was
a leftist influenced and perhaps
captured labor movement which terrified
people I mean you have to put this story
into the context of Americans America's
20th century anxieties about socialism
and communism and on the other hand a
union movement that's run by gangsters
and controlled by gangsters who are
entrepreneurs to the you know down to
their down to their bare skin and are
happy to make deals and are not
challenging you know the capitalist
system indeed our supporters are the
best exemplars of the capitalist system
so that every time there was any kind of
choice to be made between will our
destiny be a leftist dominated labor
movement or a gangster dominated labor
movement we always
in the direction of a gangster dominated
labor movement and think about the the
Palmer Raids and think about all kinds
of FBI raids on left-wing unions and the
destruction of left-wing unions and the
prosecution of subversives in the labor
movement and and you know what all that
ends up meaning for the for the outcomes
for the outcomes here while the
gangsters were pretty much left alone
the AFL during the period of the
McClellan committee hearings in 1957 to
1959 AFL and CIO combined and there's
tension there the CIO wants to know what
the AFL people are going to do about
gangsters the AFL people want to know
what the CIO people gonna do about
communists and they both agree to do
something and they throw the Teamsters
out of the out of the labor Federation
they throw out some other unions and
they that are mobbed mobbed up and they
set up an ethical practices committee
and they there starts to look like some
action but by the 1960s all that action
is over the ethical practices committee
never met again I think after 1959 or
1960 there was never even another
meeting of it and the after that time
the afl-cio leadership really took the
position that you know this all this
talk about gangsterism in the labor
movement is just another part of the
smear campaign against labor this is
just another not even so effectively
veiled effort to destroy us we're always
in battles we know what what these
government people are you know what
they're a hidden agenda really is and if
they care so much about crime why don't
they go and and and investigate the
corporation's you know and leave the
unions alone and there may be some truth
to that story but nevertheless they took
no no active role in fighting organized
crime in the labor movement for for what
ever reason I think a decision was made
among the Labour leadership of the
country that it would be worse for
labour to split and and engage in a
battle with mobsters than it would be to
just put your head in the sand get along
as best you can and forget about it they
may also have assumed that they couldn't
win that battle that many of them would
end up losing their unions in a battle
with organized crime then there the
rank-and-file members of the unions and
some of those rank-and-file members what
we call labour dissidents some of them
did did criticise and raise questions
and try to do do something and do
counter organizing but they were very
very easily defeated once the the
gangsters controlled a union and they'd
set up a patronage system they ruled
with both carrots and sticks and the
sticks are very easy to understand in in
some of the unions like the Teamsters
and longshoremen and construction you're
dealing with Union hiring halls so
you're dealing with a lot of employers
who just want workers at a certain time
and the Union is really the employer the
the the union member doesn't have a long
term relationship with any employer he's
assigned to different employers so it's
got to be on the good side of the Union
and if he starts to criticize the Union
or want to run for office god forbid
then he'll simply never get a job again
even if an employer hires him and he has
a job with an employer the union has no
difficulty at all calling the employer
up and saying you know that guy human
who works for you I know he's good at
you know he's a good warehouseman or a
good driver and I know you know that's
but we would have a much better
relationship the you and the Union
without mr. human working for you he's a
pain in the ass in the union meetings
and he'd be gone
morning and what's he gonna do complain
to the Union and ask you know them to
file a grievance with the employer it's
like a sick joke you know he could try
to go to the NLRB he could try to find a
private lawyer somewhere who might take
the case pro bono but there's almost
nothing he could do and you find when
you work in this area lots of these
Union dissidents who've been mistreated
and of course none of that works you
could you know uh to get the Union just
in and out it just beat them up or you
could kill them I have a chapter in the
book I've got a table just of cases I
found two people who were killed you
know for challenging for daring to run
for office in these unions and so on so
you know these these Union dissidents
very generally very sad very powerless
you know very paranoid and have reason
to be paranoid but very ineffective okay
so now what do I do here to get myself
get rid of this stuff and keep going
look there we go
thank you sir the the story really
starts to turn around in the post Hoover
period J Edgar Hoover died in 1972 and
at that point and III believe this is
the way the story goes I believe the FBI
at that point began to reinvent itself
and to move into a post Hoover Post
anti-communist period that doesn't mean
that they weren't still infiltrating you
know the Vietnam War groups and and and
you know other groups but I think they
really started to under new leadership
become a law enforcement agency and they
looked around and and and and began to
think about what the FBI should be doing
and what it should be focused on and
they quickly alighted upon the organized
crime figures who so brazenly and openly
were functioning around the country I
like to tell the story about my first
experience in Chicago in 1970 when I
went to the University of Chicago as a
student and we go into a bus tour in the
first day in Chicago and we take the bus
down to the center of Chicago the loop
area you've probably been to the loop
and we go in the loop and the the person
conducting the tour says this is the
center of Chicago this is the loop this
is the first Ward and this is the Mafia
Ward and you can see them out there you
know if that's their one of their
restaurants and there's a guy in a black
shirt and a white tie and they're some
of them over there and you know that
they dressed like mafioso they really
are advertising and announcing their
control over this area and what I
remember most about this is that nobody
in the bus thought oh my god I mean what
are you talking about this is the first
this is the Mafia controls the center of
Chicago doesn't anyone think this is
strange you know but no one seemed to
answer those questions that's the way it
was and there were mafia neighborhoods
in all the big cities in the United
States and indeed in New York City when
I came to New York as late as 1983 in
and I began to poke around in this
organized crime you know I was told well
the organized crime you know controls
the garment center they controlled the
garment center yeah you know everybody
who works in the garment center knows
that they control Kennedy Airport the
cargo operations at Kennedy Airport they
control the Fulton fish market the
largest retail fish market in the United
States right they controlled the Javits
Center even the Javits Center that's a
that's a state you know a public
corporation yeah even the Javits Center
that's on one of the mobs say that's
that's there's and and the docks and I'm
you know that's the way it was and that
is the way it was and when I remember
talking with mr. fortune off Allen
fortune or if the owner of fortunoff's
at the time who was a graduate of our
school and sponsored our colloquium and
he said you know Jim it's always been
that way and it will always be that way
you're wasting your time looking at this
it will never change that's what I mean
that's New York City it's amazing and
it's amazing that Robert Dahl
ask the question who governs didn't
comment on it it's amazing that Robert
Cairo who wrote a thousand pages about
Robert Moses and won the Pulitzer Prize
and talked about the greatest public
builder in the history of the United
States you know doesn't have a single
entry in the book about organized crime
despite the fact that Robert Moses is is
is building in an environment in which
in which or the organized crime families
control all the unions in in you know in
construction how is that possible son I
don't know that's just the way it is i
bt local 560 here in new jersey
all good things start in new jersey this
was the largest Teamster Union in in New
Jersey it was controlled by Tony
Provenzano and when he went to prison by
his brothers and when they went to
prison by his daughter and when they
when she was thrown out by other front
men for the provenzano family the New
Jersey US Attorney's Office brought a
civil Rico action and throughout the the
leadership and they had a trustee put in
there and the trustee you know fought
for the body and soul of that Union for
over 10 years and after after over 10
years they achieved quite a bit and
brought in a new leadership and expelled
all kinds of people and really turned it
around in 1988 it was rumored that Rudy
Giuliani the ambitious US Attorney in
the Southern District of New York was
planning a civil Rico suit patterned
after the the one against the local in
566 years earlier and there had been
several others against locals but no one
had thought about bringing a civil Rico
suit against you know an entire National
Union to the Teamsters have 600 locals
they they covered the entire North
America their leaders have I mean how
powerful or I mean their leaders have
the power to
up the telephone and get the United the
President of the United States on the
phone I mean the Teamsters bark and
people tremble and so and there was a
rumor that he and his staff were
planning to bring a civil rico suit
against the Teamsters Union and the
response was was a tremendous
overwhelming response over 280 members
of your Congress brought a petition to
the Attorney General of the United
States demanding that the so called
rumored Rico suit that was was was
rumored to being a imminently filed
against the Teamsters Union not be
brought because according to 280
congressmen it would destroy a free and
democratic and independent labor
movement in the United States one could
get cynical one could get cynical and
the suit was brought in 1988 it was it
was settled in 1989 with many of the
members of the general Executive Board
resigning a trustee ship set up over the
Teamsters Union and that trustees ship
has lasted how long let's see that
trusteeship is still going now in 2006
so that's 17 years later it has expelled
over 500 officials from the Teamsters
Union with with one wave of hearings
after another against one local after
another 500 officials of the Teamsters
Union over 17 years and there's not a
mention of this case in the labor law
textbooks used in American law schools I
did a study of the labor law case books
and none of them mention it maybe I'm
over the top and my colleagues in labor
law are right that it's not important
enough yet to warrant a mention in their
case books there's so many more
important topics in labor law there have
been 21 civil RICO suits that have been
brought since the first one in Union
City the government has never lost one
of these civil RICO suits all but two
have been settled
the rest the other two that went to
trial were won by the government to all
the settlements put into place all of
them trustees and and there is an entire
history of these trustees you know
battling to reform the the unions and
and battling for the hearts and soul of
the union members there's a lot here
that I think hasn't has a kind of
uncanny parallel with the the attempt to
democratize Iraq so the people that
started these suits thought that if only
you could offer freedom to the members
of these corrupted unions they would
embrace freedom they would throw out the
tyrants who had dominated them and
looted them and raped them for all these
decades and and create democratic unions
but that has sadly not happened except
in a few of the cases and and so these
these have all been battles and instead
of being greeted as liberators
you know Allah the the fantasy we had in
Iraq they've often been been greeted as
oppressors here's the government they're
you know it's government men and you
know give us back the mobsters or maybe
don't give us back the mobsters but
leave us alone the last one of these
suits was filed - the most recent one
excuse me in July of 2005 just last July
and finally this was the civil
racketeering suit against the
International Longshoremen's Association
the last of the four dirty international
unions that had not been recode as we
say in the business and so now that case
is pending and there's a trial date set
and you probably see it written about on
the front pages of the newspapers this
is in my view this effort to reform
organized crime controlled unions
perhaps the most ambitious effort at
court-supervised
organizational reform in United States
history and and I don't
say that in any way to disparage the
amazing efforts to reform the schools
and to desegregate the schools and to
reform the prisons and to and the mental
hospitals and to bring their conditions
up to a constitutional minimum but in
all of those cases we were dealing with
government officials albeit many times
bad government officials and and and and
bad people but still they weren't
mobsters that wasn't the Mafia right and
while they were government officials
they were in schools they were in
prisons that were mental hospitals they
were peripheral figures in our political
life and our economic life I mean these
are not the kind of people that can pick
up the phone and speak to the Secretary
of Labor you know or the president's
counsel or the chief of staff or the
president himself
I mean when you are trying to to through
court supervision reform the the
Teamsters Union the largest private
sector union in the country a union that
can mobilize 280 members of Congress to
deliver a petition to the to the
Attorney General
you're talking about attacking the power
structure of the country and it's in
that way a scene in that way it's
remarkable that such suits were ever
brought right remarkable that this could
have happened and in very few countries
could anything like this ever happen you
know it's very difficult to investigate
and prosecute people you know at the
highest levels of power in any society
so in that way we ought to feel good
about good about this and and that the
effort has continued under Republican
and Democratic presidents but you know
with lots of criticism and of course
some of the biggest critics have been
the Hollywood movie stars who who in the
early years of these suits are joined
torchlight parades you know for free
labor movement and so forth they had all
kinds of the the mob guys had all kinds
of dummy organizations Teamsters for
liberty
and so forth and you know talked about
all this as the Reagan and Giuliani
trying to destroy labor and and and so
forth well there's a tremendous need
here an enormous crying need for
scholarly attention and for evaluation
by scholars and and and and by
journalists that people need to look
into these suits and to see what's
worked what hasn't worked and amazingly
enough to my knowledge and I I think I
know quite a bit about this stuff
there's never been a conference ever on
this subject of these trustees ships the
trustees themselves have never been
brought together for a workshop or a
conference the National Institute of
Justice has never shown the slightest
bit of interest in finding out what's
going on so that every suit that's filed
has to begin all over again reinventing
the wheel trying to find strategies of
remediation and and figuring out what
powers the trustee needs and how to fund
the trustees and who the trustees should
be it's really really quite remarkable
we don't even have a good
conceptualization of what counts as
success my view is that success depends
upon at least purging the known
organized crime people and their allies
from the Union sometimes you don't know
of course who they are and secondly of
fostering democracy at least trying to
see whether we've created a situation
where people are willing to run for
office and where people will come
forward and sometimes we we have seen
that and certainly one mark of success
is where you have a complete break with
the old regime where you have a new
leadership which which really has no
links to the past and and I would say
out of the 21 lawsuits maybe four or
five have have reached that point where
I would be willing to say we see
now and I say we have maybe maybe
another four or five maybe more where it
definitely didn't work where the where
the trusteeship ended maybe the judge
lost interest the government lost
interest something no more money
something happened and it's still in the
same hands of the same clique and the
rest are still still too soon to say
just a few reflections before I stop the
importance of this study for our
understanding of organized crime in
short in brief I believe that what I
what I've shown here is that organized
crime
the Italian American version of
organized crime the Mafia families are
distinctive in American history because
of their position as in as power brokers
in urban America because they sat at the
seat of power and it was their position
their influence in the labor movement
that gave them their position as power
brokers right in it's for that reason
that they differ from all other at least
contemporary organized crime groups and
so when people ask me well when the
Mafia is defeated what who will come
next there's no other group that has
that thank God that power in American
politics and American economy that the
traditional mafia families families have
you have to go to Italy itself and look
at the way that the organized crime
groups operate in Italy very close to
the seat of power or in Japan where
organized crime groups have that same
position right at the core of the
Japanese political and economic system
to find something that looks like what
we have in the United States or at least
what we had in the United States
obviously there's there's important
lessons here for the labor movement you
know the we don't understand the labor
movement in our labor history we don't
to stand the degree to which labor the
labor movement was compromised and
undermined by the existence of gangsters
in that movement in everything that I've
read about the decline of the labor
movement from its peak in the late 1950s
where almost 1/3 of private-sector
workers were in unions too now with less
than 10% in private sector unions I've
never seen any reference any suggestion
that the organized crime presence in the
unions might be a contributing factor I
don't say the most important factor
there are lots of important factors
globalization the the loss of of
industry the movement of industry south
and employers into this into the Sun
Belt a lot of things that I might put
before organized-crime but I would
certainly put organized-crime on the
list the fact that major unions in the
United States like the Teamsters Union
the laborers Union the major unions were
were were substantially controlled and
dominated by by criminals you know who
were in there for what they could get
for themselves and their families not
for their unions and who put into
positions of importance in those unions
you know ex-cons and friends and family
members not cutting edge labor
organizers this must have consequences
for the the history of the labor
movement that played out you know from
throughout most of the 20th century and
yet I you know all of these labor
scholars is never I've never seen it
even alluded to there has to be
importance here for American society in
general certainly it helps to explain
our urban history I believe that at the
core of our urban politics there was a
quadripartite alliance between organized
crime the political machines the the
business community and and and is that
for
three so I've got labour organized crime
business and and and local government
yes so and the Machine so you know you
have this this Alliance and this is what
the that's who governed you know and
that's that's how it was in in in
throughout much of the 20th century and
I I find this very useful in in
discussions with colleagues who are
talking about their cynicism about the
potential for democracy in Russia and in
other countries in transition and people
say we have given up on Russia it's too
much crime too much corruption they
can't possibly have a democracy in a
society that looks like that and I
wonder you know I mean you I mean what
planet are we living on here what do you
think our history look like suppose if
you could go back to our cities in 1930
1940 1950 and and and you know the
Kefauver committee the McClellan
committee you know it puts a different
spin on thinking about stages of
democracy and of whether how whether
democracy can in some way be compatible
with with gangsterism it tells us
something I think about American
exceptionalism there's a lot of
discussion in the Academy I mean to you
know to what extent is is America
exceptional I mean and and and how and
why have we diverged from the other
Western democracies I wonder you know if
we could play a kind of antics have an
experiment and take the counterfactual
what would America look like if we
didn't have this history of labor
racketeering right if you took the
gangsters out of the American labor
movement would we have a labor movement
that looks like the labor movements in
Europe would we have a Labor Party in
the United States would labor be the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
would we have a
different kind of welfare state in the
United States more like Western Europe
had history not taking us in this
direction
we won't know but I think it is
interesting to pose the question and it
helps to put in perspective you know the
the the importance of this phenomenon
that I'm writing about and finally I
just say that to me one of the most
interesting aspects of it all is what
accounts for the inattention of American
intellectuals American Historians
American political scientists American
sociologists and legal academics to this
to this very obvious you know a problem
and these very obvious facts about our
history and about our politics I mean I
didn't do investigative journalism I
didn't discover this right this isn't
something oh you know I went out with a
magnifying glass I looked in the
crevices and I found something people
know about this I mean this is stuff on
the public record
they knew you know and yet they chose
not to know
at the same time thank you
you mentioned the movement in the 70s of
the FBI to to get more interesting this
what about the main what about lawyers
and justice was that didn't do that
follow didn't make lawyers at the main
justice gets similarly interested or
they leave that to the locals like
Giuliani in the Southern District on the
district New Jersey people I understand
the history you know Bobby Kennedy was
very interested he was in the McClellan
committee right so you had this enormous
investigation of of labor racketeering
they didn't quite understand organized
crime but they but but the corrupt they
saw it as kind of corruption and and and
a danger in the labor movement between
57 to 59 Robert Kennedy becomes Attorney
General in 61 when his brother becomes
president and he's his first priority is
to get Hoffa and he forms these squads
and they start going after the Teamsters
in particular and organized crime in
general they tried to get Hoover to to
get on board at Hoover is very reluctant
and you know that he gives them the
worst agents and you know the drunks and
the burned out they do a little bit but
after John Kennedy is assassinated and
Bobby Kennedy leaves there's not much
going on in the Justice Department after
that after that I think the energy comes
from the FBI right and then the FBI I
think the
gets the the local US Attorney's
involved that's the way I would read it
anyway for the apparent paradox in the
fact that you stated that you know
unions were so powerful they can contact
the president they controlled everything
and at the same time within 17 years you
got rid of five hundred leaders right
away and then my second question is just
while writing this book did you ever
feel like threatened or have any
personal fear for what would happen
after you published it take the first
the first the second question first
so I I haven't had any any fear we don't
have a history of organized crime thank
goodness coming after academics you know
in in the US so I was feeling pretty
good but the prosecution of John Gotti
junior for the assassination of attempt
on Curtis Lee was made me a little
worried you know because he was
denouncing the you know on this radio
program and you know they go after and
try to kill I mean you know what is that
about right usually they don't care
about that kind of thing but all the
work that I've done you know comes from
the public record this is not an expose
I haven't double-crossed anybody but you
know I to be honestly I'm a little more
worried about unions than I am about
organized crime because you know you
have some loose cannons in unions I have
encountered in the past some opposition
some antagonism by unions and in the
when I started this work in the late 80s
with the with the New York State
organized crime task force and we we had
wrote a report on the corruption and
racketeering of the construction
industry in New York and we brought our
preliminary report in the late 80s maybe
was nineteen ninety by then to the
Cornell industrial and labor relations
press they thought oh this is phenomenal
I mean this this is great we're going to
publish the report as is and and and and
they did to their credit and two years
later we had the final report so it was
about about another you know twice as
large and it had a lot more mature
we brought it to them it's okay here's
the final report and the tone had
changed completely and they said you
know we're just not sure about this you
know we've had a lot of complaints from
alumni we've had a lot of complaints
from our labor constituency we're not
saying we won't publish it but we'll
have to go through a very rigorous
peer-review process and this ha bla bla
bla bla and it was clear that they
weren't going to publish it actually you
know what is their objection they said
well you know the labor unions are very
angry with us and in fact one has
threatened me personally threatened me
with physical harm and I said well
what's you know this isn't an ant first
of all I said you know your Cornell
University Press you know what is this
Russia
you can only publish things that did the
union's like I mean that's okay with you
and what does that say to young labor
scholars if you want to get tenure you
know and you want to publish in the
premier press you you really can do
anything you want but as long as it's
it's you know politically correct and
its really amazed by that and yeah but
you know is that and and I said but you
know and secondly and this is of much
less importance this isn't anti-union I
mean this is no more anti-union than
writing about family violence is
anti-family
I mean we're talking here about the the
exploitation of the labor movement by
organized criminals I mean how do you
get this to be an anti-union story right
well you know so they wouldn't publish
it and we called some other presses and
I gave them full disclosure and and
about about three or four of them
immediately said you know we're not
going to touch that you know we got
enough labor problems to begin with
finally the NYU press agreed to do it
and I told them then you know I don't
know how influential this was with them
well thank you and I'll publish there
any other books on this area with you
and I've stuck to that even though the
people that made that that heroic
offered to me aren't even there anymore
so there were other presses I don't know
why I keep honoring that so your other
your first question was a it was a
question and you want to just restate
that right right right now why was the
suit brought and how come it wasn't
stopped how come it wasn't stopped in
various parts along the way when you
know Nixon pardoned Hoffa you know in a
quid pro quo for the you know the
endorsement of the Teamsters right and
if you looked at when Bush was elected
president Jimmy Hoffa jr. was you know
in the in the Box there you know or
maybe he was at the State of the Union
and so on and so forth I mean how come a
deal wasn't struck and you know and they
forced the the government to back off
and you know put some face saving you
know a solution on this and I think
really what it would what's happened
here is we have developed a very
independent and very powerful law
enforcement sector and and it is
somewhat protected from politics I mean
even the president you know can't mess
too much by but and in the politicians
by calling up the US Attorney's and
telling them to back off and ordering
them to do things and so forth II the
scandal potential is just too great at
least that's the story that I'm the only
explanation that makes make sense to me
is it's just too much risk in doing that
civil RICO case against the ILA because
the feds lost a major case against them
in November and they went home as heroes
basically they're all acquitted you know
including the guy who disappeared on the
trial was found in a trunk
he was acquitted as well so I guess they
were trying to lay some of the predicate
you know issues from the RICO suit what
happens now
but the suit you know you know traces a
whole pattern of racketeering and
control and so forth I mean it's because
hundred and something pages so I don't
really think that that suit is going to
be is going to matter you know I think
this case will go forward and I think
that you know they have a very very
powerful complaint as I say they've
never lost one of these cases so you'd
hate to be the AUSA you know who loses
the first one right your career is over
you know you'll be the guy that lost the
ILA case it's unthinkable right so we'll
see we'll see what happens I you know
all of them have settled for the last
you know so many years so you know if
history is to be a guide they'll work
out some kind of settlement here maybe
that those developments will somehow
factor into the leverage of the
settlement you know but I would be
surprised I mean I don't think they just
walk away from the suit I have a
two-part question actually the the first
one would be do you think the turn from
the law enforcement component of this
whole picture was changed because until
80s I say until Giuliani took that case
and if I found it officials
representatives were replaced by others
was because until then as you had said
the the politics were more focused or
the law enforcement was more focused on
keeping the lefties out of the unions
and until then Union
in the surfing output I'm Union and
proud of it and there was this
nationalistic nationalist tone to it
with the wars going on and everything in
50s of Korea and then 70s 60s 70s
there's Vietnam and afterward in after
80s with liberalisation special
privatizations that started in England
and you had a flexible labor being
introduced to the whole scene production
arena and also after 80s and especially
90s we had a lot more part-time people
working unions didn't represent the
major body of labor actually in the
States but part-time and people doing
more than two or three jobs at a time
and representing that was the labor
force in the state
maybe Giuliani's or
the change that happened law enforcement
was to create to tone down the
nationalist voice in there and and the
corrupt organized crime component and
introduced a new face that would avail
that would sort of push back labor
unions a little bit and then make space
for flexible labor which means now you
know Union at all and make space for all
the other companies that relied on not
union workers but just everybody very
much on part-time and no benefits
nothing and the second question let's
just take that one that's a big question
and see what I can do about that
you know one thing to think about is is
it the suits were brought in new york
and new jersey i mean these were still
places where labor had a lot of power so
i think that's kind of interesting
though labor was substantially weakened
in other places in you know the first
suits Philadelphia and New York and
and New Jersey suggests to me that it
wasn't so much that labor had become
weaker that enabled that gave the space
for Giuliani to to bring the suit I
think what happened more was that the
the federal law enforcement had become
stronger and had become more independent
and this was not viewed by I believe by
the architects of the lawsuits as an
effort to clean up labor I mean this was
and I this is a point I should have made
in my in my remarks more clearly this
was about the attack on organized crime
so this followed you know from the plan
that was hatched in the 1970s that we
want to destroy the Mafia in the United
States it's an open affront to law
enforcement into you know the decency in
America to have these mobsters it has to
be destroyed and going after one of its
bases of power in the labor movement was
just a strategy to purge or and destroy
organized crime at the same time they
will bring a lot of other suits and you
know the the Commission case and the the
Pizza connection case and all of the
prosecution's of the organized crime
that bosses that occurred in the 1980s
as well so I think they the story that
the law enforcement people were telling
themselves it had nothing to do with
labor you know and I don't really think
they knew or cared one way or another
whether we had a democratic labor
movement and whether people were getting
their landrum-griffin rights I mean I
suppose if you would put the question to
them they would have said of course you
know democracy is good and
landrum-griffin but they were zeroed in
on destroying the Mafia I don't know
that this could have happened under a
Democratic administration and would be
harder for the Democrats a Democratic
administration to let this occur it
happened under the Reagan administration
but it continued under Carter and it
continued
under Clinton as well so once it got
started it wasn't derailed very much two
observations I'd be curious to your
reaction first I read what happened at
DOJ a little bit differently I don't
think it was an independent DOJ that was
just pursuing the Mafia and targeted the
labor movement I think Reagan signaled a
weakened labor movement in the late 70s
and he signaled with PATCO that it was
time to take down the labor movement and
this was part of the process of taking
down the labor movement so I don't think
this was independent they're all I think
was very political and in that respect I
disagree with I disagree with that
entirely I don't think that is in any
way an accurate reading of the history
of what happened well so your second
Dobbs on your second second let's go to
your set let's go to your second okay
second I think that you know you make
many points as to why the labor movement
is easy to capture I do agree with them
I think you're right but I think there's
also a more important institutional
floor structural flaw in labor unions or
local labor unions as institutions and
that is these are supposed to be the
most inherently democratic organizations
where workers band together and they
take control of their own destiny the
problem is they're not that because it
takes too damn much work and too much
expertise and what happens is workers
are tired and and they have limited
attention spans so right now you see
workers in local 100 TWU very active
it's a contract time they're very
democratically involved but mostly
workers have to elect leaders to control
these organizations the workers don't
have the skills or the time or the
energy to the favored workers don't have
any beefs anyway they have a good
contract and the membership whether it's
I'm sorry the leadership whether it's
mob leadership or not mob leadership
wind up developing a set of interests
that's really distinct from their
members interests and I think that this
is an institutional flaw in labor unions
that that really is irreconcilable with
model we have of labor unions I think
this opens the ground also besides the
other points you make for the mob to
walk right in I think that's true too
I agree with that and I do point a so
there we have an agreement disease we
know we just ran everything we agree on
half of what you said the there is this
there is this agent here there is this
agency problem in unions it's very hard
for members of unions to monitor their
their managers you know their principals
and once people get control of unions
they're rarely defeated you know by any
kind of outside outside movements so in
that way they you know you know did the
history the way the way unions are
structured I just repeating your point I
think you're right about that it doesn't
explain why it's organized crime and not
other other bosses other other other
kind of dictators and unions we've had
some of those right
it sounds like Rico was really crucial
to this effort to break the stranglehold
and I wondered if you could just talk a
little more about you know what is it
about Rico that provides some
opportunities for making these cases
successful that other statutes didn't
didn't offer right well was the civil
Rico here and there are two kinds of
civil Rico there was the civil Rico that
that in the statute that gave a right to
bring a lawsuit to the victims of
racketeering and said the victims could
sue for treble-damages that is the the
section of the of the statute that's
been very controversial in commercial
litigation where one company Sue's
another in a contract case for
racketeering it's never been used in an
organized crime case for obvious reasons
people don't sue the mob you know
claiming they were victims and asking
for treble damages so it's never
happened the other section of Rico which
allows the Attorney General or the
Department of Justice to sue for
equitable relief for injunctions and for
these trustees and so forth has been
absolutely as you say of vital
importance
there is no this is a good example I'm
glad you asked that question of of an
expansion in our thinking about Crime
Control and about organized crime
control we have had a lot of innovation
in Crime Control in the last couple of
decades from forfeitures on the one hand
to all kinds of civil penalties on the
other hand and this is a very good good
example when you're dealing with
systemic criminality right by an
organization that's taken over a union
like the Provenza knows a criminal
prosecution has no impact on the problem
if the problem is a is a is a captured
labor union in the hands of organized
crime convicting some people has no
impact you know they just put another
person in and another person in it it
doesn't affect operations at all so the
civil Rico you know enabled the
government to come in and and like in
the prison context or the schools
context put a trustee on the ground to
run the Union to to bring disciplinary
charges against people to to vet the
list of people running for office in the
Union to try to encourage rank-and-file
is to to become politically active so
none of that could have been done
without civil Rico there just was no
other law and and it couldn't have been
done just relying on cron on criminal
prosecutions so we really see here how
the civil side right is working in
conjunction with the criminal side and
really how arbitrary that distinction
between civil and criminal is really
very fascinating talk and one of the
things that I found particularly
interesting was looking at the RICO
suits as an example of institutional
reform litigation that worked and so one
could speculate a lot about why it works
better against the unions than it
against governments which is usually
where it's involved i was curious
whether you had any sense of who the
defense lawyers were in these kinds of
case and what and what kind of role they
played were they the same lawyers who
were related to the Union and the mobs
when they were in power or did they
change lawyers to get lawyers who could
try to get them out of this as easily as
they could and did the lawyers where was
the lawyer stand visa vie their
obligations to the Union and their
obligations to the union leaders who
were the people who are getting kicked
out and and what did that do and to what
extent did the defense lawyers what role
do they play in this successful reform
litigation okay no those are those are
great questions and just I want to try
to try to clarify what I was saying
about the remediation there have been
successes in the remediation effort and
in these civil RICO suits and there have
been failures there have been cases of
total failure you know where you know
the the trustees ship ends and a year
later the US Attorney brings another
suit exposing the the Carpenters Union
in New York the District Council is a
great example of that you know the you
know the new clique that takes over the
Union they're indicted for exactly the
same thing taking bribes with organized
crime from contractors doing the same
thing so I wouldn't say I would not
reach the conclusion that this is
successful in comparison to the efforts
to remediate prisons and mental
hospitals some of them been successful
and some of them haven't and that's true
in the prison area as well and it has
the its own problems and dynamics
dynamics here and remind me the second
question
oh yeah the defense lawyers right well
of course the the the lawyers who are on
the civil Rico a lot of them are labor
lawyers and a lot of them are big firm
labor lawyers either from labor law
firms
you know the the big establishment labor
law firms and some in some cases like in
Chicago they're really politically
connected firms you know and and what
they've done mostly is is negotiate the
negotiate the settlements and and and so
forth so I don't think that we've ever
seen in these cases the a lawyer for the
Union you know taking a stand separate
from the from the officers III haven't
seen I haven't seen that generally their
their stand has been the same and
there's been there's been a lot of
solidarity there what we haven't seen is
something like in the corporate area
which is maybe what you're thinking
about where the corporation hires
lawyers who represent the corporation
they turn on the on the former
executives and they're willing to waive
lawyer-client privilege and you know do
anything you know to cooperate with the
government and they they just throw the
former these former CEOs and corporate
officers to the Wolves so that that's
become de rigueur in in in white-collar
crime prosecutions I haven't seen that
know something rather startling about
the deep penetration of organized crime
into police departments and even
prosecutorial officers does that mean
that if we look at the last don'ts
eighty years when we studied police
departments we study courts that really
we should revisit all of those studies
or I mean is this just anecdotal
evidence or is this real I'm you know
occasional graft the cage election or do
we really have some evidence on what
evidence do we have this was deep
penetration well I think it's pretty
anecdotal I mean you know it's the stuff
that comes out in you know in in in by
investigative journalists by
congressional committees the heat look
they you know go back and look at the
Kefauver what are we what was the
Kefauver committee in 1951 and they take
a look at local corruption and all the
sudden this thing starts to take on a
they have hearings in different cities
in every city people are starting to ask
about the police chief and the
prosecutors and the organized crime guys
and after about a year they just slam
the lid closed on it there's too much
political heat right so you know III
think that there's anecdotal evidence at
best you know that you know police
departments in the big cities are have a
lot of a lot of penetration by organized
crime I don't know about the prosecutors
offices but I think some there as well I
could say well you know just for one
fact is they didn't certainly didn't go
after organized crime now you could say
part of is they didn't have the tools to
go after organized crime and police
departments aren't set up for that kind
of proactive investigation but I think
you know this isn't at the heart of my
book I would say that it's you know it's
it's it's a it's a suggestion that comes
from this I I do think that it's true
though and I do think if you studied
police departments and you went deep
into the history of Police Department
you'd find very close connections
interestingly enough was it just this
month where they brought out the real a
the the fact that the two New York City
police officers or detectives or hitmen
for the mob you know how much of that
has going on and and this is now 2005
think about what it looked like in 1940s
and 1950s prerogative - yeah it's about
9:30 was that we'll have cookies and
coffee and we'll talk out there
anybody ask questions I mean it's really
rather remarkable if you know Jim really
awakened a lot of things in me his talk
if you grew up in New York some of you
grew up in New York I hope I mean we had
all of these things that you spoke about
Bensonhurst on Bay Ridge was the
neighborhood to the Mafia control there
was no crime safest neighborhood you
could walk through there at night no one
was scared you never thought twice about
it we all knew about all the Mafia
places including kosher chicken industry
in New York including various Kate
we halls various Caden roles you knew
you got a better price because the mob
control them the whole series of those
and of course there were all these other
we just knew these things and also when
I teach this stuff I always say you know
the studies Jim is right skirt the heart
of what he's talking about like Frances
I Annie but he's very politically
correct it took about ethnic succession
and this is a very brutal his talk
tonight was very forthright about the
Italian connection the putative Italian
connection to organized crime I'm
hedging my bets and I Annie spoke about
how did Jews were in it in the Italians
were in it and the Russians are in it in
the agents are in it etc I found these
questions about why Robert Dahl those
are your political scientist is sort of
the bit you know one of the top books of
the 20th century it is rather startling
that who governs and you know if you're
in new New Haven I mean clearly there's
a strong organized crime presence and it
really is not mention there which is
maybe what a book ultimately proved to
be wrong or in a book about Robert Moses
I mean that's just startling I think in
some ways Jim bringing his stuff
together was one of those four days it's
a little most paranoid shifting you know
why is it I mean his question I can't
answer he can't answer discretion why is
this ignored why do you want we all have
these anecdotes we all shrug you don't
say that's the way it is and I don't
think we'll ever think that way again
but on the other hand unlike Jim we
won't be afraid to start our car this
evening uh thank you very much
James Jacobs is director of the Center
for research in crime and justice at New
York University School of Law for more
information on him and his work